so i used to work at productions and
travel bird before as a data scientist
building data products
in you know an organization so you know
taking care of your models as you ship
them is something that i have suffered
from to a certain extent i used to do
research before that
but i kind of got into
coding uh quite a lot for during that
research and i thought maybe
maybe i should you know get paid for
that rather than get paid for renting
grants that you never get and you have
to move around to uh you know research a
topic that usually nobody cares for
so that's a little bit about me um
so actually um i'll start with a sort of
like cautionary tale um i don't know if
you uh
if you've heard of of of zillow it's a
u.s company that
was using ml quite heavily for
quite a lot of their um
let's say
decision uh making uh or even automated
decision making so it happened that okay
i have to like turn and move this
microphone a little bit so i can i mean
actually i should look at this but it's
a bit far um
actually i'll just do that so um it
turns out that um in q3 and 4 of 2021 um
zillow
ended up estimating by over 500 million
dollars um
a um the price of of the value of houses
to to purchase
um so this kind of like led them to uh
quite significant losses um as as
written here uh and they even had to
fire a bunch of people because they they
had made so many bad decisions um
so this coincided actually with a strong
sort of change in uh market housing
conditions that caused the prices to
fall their models had been trained on a
market that was going up
um so
there is kind of you know probably so
quite quite a lot of strong evidence
around here is that they kind of like
you know used their models the models
were very good they believed in them and
they kind of let them to
to to decay
so
before we go into like bashing a company
for doing that um that's not the aim of
the talk right did they do everything
badly uh no actually they did a lot of
really you know standard stuff that you
would do they train their models regular
rigorously that's always a word that
that hurts me
um during during testing and development
right they they did that they then
released their models um gradually you
know usually like tracking a bunch of
kpis making sure that you know it it
plays well and then you know scale it up
and serve it to more and more and
eventually you start believing in a
model and you're like yeah good let's
let's take into account this this input
um
you know so the typical sort of life
cycle of you know you've got a bunch of
very clever data scientists working on a
model
they do all their uh goodness they put
it to prod and um and you know above
your uncle you're making profit
um so any good data scientist team would
actually do all of these steps um that's
and and and they do right in general
um
but could could it have been avoided uh
most likely yes um so obviously we know
um that stuff in nature changes all
right that's that's just the the reality
of things and since we generally try to
model some
natural or artificial or some phenomenon
um things change and therefore um
and also you know pricing is definitely
one that changes quite quite
significantly
um so
this this common pattern causes what we
generally refer to as uh data drift or
concept rift labeled with all of these
drift
relatives uh we'll talk a bit a little
bit about this
but basically what happens um is is
something changes in between the moment
you trained your model and and and later
um and any good data science team is
aware of that like very much but
generally
there's no time for you know slapping
yet another um piece of code or infra
that you know sort of maintains and
checks all of these things that you know
will change in the future
um sometimes you don't necessarily know
which ones will change in the future so
you kind of
you know would end up having to
verify all of your input features over
time build kind of a bunch of code and
all that the
bold claim of this is that really it
isn't so much the the core job of it of
a data science team like there was a
talk this morning that talked about you
know um it was the gpu talk when where
data scientists are really busy at the
top of level they're busy you know
making a model that works well
understanding the domain problem
you know building the stuff that
predictions are good do they want to
necessarily have to slap a bunch of code
to perform validations well
probably that's usually something that
ends up like on your backlog and as we
know all things that end up on the
backlog
go to die
so you know that's it's actually not an
uncommon thing right and i think
every
data team at some point probably ran
into this it maybe didn't bid them in
the ass so much as it did for zillow but
um or they their the impact of the
decision model was maybe less crucial
but we've all been there if we've put
some model into prod unless you know you
you use something or you you've got a
modern day data stack and you have all
of the the stuff that allows you to also
um apply data validation
kind of as an easy extra small step
so really um this you know the the thing
that i want to convince about that was
the
sort of subtitle was this talk is like
it's important to think about data
quality
and probably a very good idea to use a
framework that allows you to do this and
we've we've heard about a lot of them
today so um you know
but just before we go into this a little
bit i'll just take a detour into
datadrift just in case um anyone is
still unsure what i mean with this it'll
be very
high level it's the end of the day uh i
you know it's not necessary to go too
much into the maths of it
but here are two examples you have um i
don't know how to do the little thingy
or yeah where you so here let's imagine
it's it's fake data that i generated
using a normal distribution you know in
real life things don't look like this
but for today they will
and we have here like um distribution of
some order prices right maybe something
that you just you would put in say let's
say a linear regression because we're
going to keep things simple today to
predict some
some decision it could be buy or not buy
or
is valid orders or not or predict some
time series and whatever
this is the state of the data as you
train it right you train your model and
maybe you've learned to do something if
it's above the mean then some decision
will come up if it's below some decision
will you know come down or something
like that let's you know keep it to a
simple example even there you train this
you've got your model it works you've
you know sort of tested um that it works
in practice with a bunch of real data
all of that stuff you've you know
deployed your model and it's all fun and
then you know later on down the line
something changes about a lower price it
could be because the underlying nature
of things have changed could be you have
a problem in your transformation you've
just
added some business logic that's faulty
or whatever
and you end up with a system that
in the future looks maybe a little
shifted so this is just you know i
took the normal distribution again with
a mean of 650 and here i have this plot
um
so really what is data drift is
basically um at least when we call and
and this is this is about features right
so like stuff that you would put into
your model to get a prediction out of it
um
it happens when the distribution of one
or more of your input features is
changed between for example the training
time and the deployment time or
time and in in the you know life cycle
of your model this happens to features
it can happen to labels as well or it
can happen to the predictions that come
out of your model so literally you could
look at drift in in all of the places
before it gets into the model but also
what comes out of the model
can change because usually what comes
into the model has also changed all this
this stuff um but basically data drift
or concept
label drift covariate drift which is the
both of them happening at the same time
they're all something that basically
happened when the shape let's say it's
called the shape of the of the data has
kind of changed over time
um so how do you detect it well
in this particular example we're taking
this this scenario of um
you've done something you've validated
everything works well at
training or development time and you've
put your model into production
what you in general want to be doing is
something that goes along this sort of
simple scenario right you have your
model's data
around training time you know what it
looks like or you want to make sure that
you know what it looks like in one way
shape or form so you want to sort of
freeze a reference distribution perhaps
right kind of capture something that
tells you this data looks like this at
time end so my order price in that
example is normally distributed uh with
a mean of 500 okay
and then you want to use that reference
distribution perhaps as you as you go
you know every day every week like how
however many times you might want to
peek into the the quality of your data
um and then you basically say well
is the you know distribution of this
feature or set of features today still
looking like what it used to look like
at the time i knew it looked good
that sort of makes sense in principle
that's pretty simple um you you end up
doing
basically
you end up probably saving some some
kind of histogram maybe
um or some kind of probability density
function that you can use to sort of
remember that or you end up maybe
capturing a sample of data and put it
into like a storage place like s3 or
whatever
and then you you know have
some automation that goes and checks the
data now compares it to this using very
standard and distribution comparison
methods such as like
smirnoff tests skype squares uh
earth move or distance psi like there is
a flurry of algorithms they all have
their assumptions and their quirks um
and and and that's fine but
the idea is that right and it's simple
in principle it's not like you know if
you can build your recommendation model
or your prediction of everything model
you you can definitely implement those
but
you implement those
implementing those still results in in
writing a bunch of stuff for it um
so that brings me to the importance of a
data quality framework whichever it is i
happen to work for soda so i'll talk
about something but in intrinsically you
should not ask of your teams or data
teams to necessarily focus on building
that especially for teams that don't
have this capacity in-house right like a
lot of teams
are small and in in some organizations
you want to have a team that's going to
give you value maybe you don't
necessarily have a staff of
ml ops engineers or data engineers that
can build you a platform for this
i happen to be working in a team where
we ended up re-implementing yet another
framework because the frameworks at the
time weren't so so good but you know
that's basically nowadays there are
frameworks out there you should probably
use one
um
so
and and that's kind of what i wanted to
that's kind of what what i alluded to is
that it's it's simply put it's you just
have to write a lot more code
um right um you have to first of all
think about oh what are the methods that
we can use for this particular problem
that's a little bit of research
luckily the internet is there then you
have to orchestrate the checks like when
do you run then how often do you run
them where okay do i put it um do i put
it as the code of the ml model like we
saw for example like so with with the
talk earlier like so
is it that is it something that runs in
parallel kind of every now and then
all of these kind of decisions you have
to make and you have to potentially
write something to orchestrate it then
you have to think about okay well i
don't want to write this specifically
for every model maybe i start to want to
make it reusable now you're already
writing yet another framework um
the list goes on right so
it's that's why i'm saying it's hard
it's not complicated in general to
assert quality of data um
at least four eighty percent of the
things you want to check
but
it is hard to do it as part of your
normal life cycle um if if you don't
have a framework perhaps or a team that
can build you one
um
so the idea again for this this thing of
you know use something that allows you
to do this is you don't want to add time
to your release right like deploying ml
automation already takes time and
resources like your data scientists are
already
um
busy doing something very complex and
and clever and
adding you know stuff like data quality
monitoring on top just makes everything
go um extra long um and you know that's
that's where i was saying it ends up on
the backlog usually
so wouldn't it be nice if you could
ultimately as you're about to uh ship
your model or you have your had your
model in in production for a while do
something like this um
right so let's imagine i'm checking my
orders table so this is this is by the
way this is a piece of dsl of soda so
i'm gonna present you a feature that
that we've that we've built um but you
know you'd want to do something like
that it doesn't matter who does it but
we happened to do it
pretty well because of that
new language that we sort of came up
with which is called soda cl
some of you probably heard it around
but it's a way to basically write um
instructions to
get something done um and we've got a
built-in for this this idea is you know
write a district like do distribution
difference on this column of my data
sets very you know small example here uh
using this uh reference
reference distribution you can talk a
bit about why the syntax looks like this
and then a sort of score or threshold
that you want to look at because i'm
using a ks test a kolmogorov smirnoff
test
this one is always um
i'm asserting this thing of
if it is above
p 0
a p value of 0.05
then i have a problem because the
distributions are statistically
significantly different
so it's always a bit weird with p values
because it brings you you know
it makes you double negate a lot
um and then we have here like a place
where we hold this reference file we've
actually
got this this way so that you you
actually can use this without storing
data anywhere you can store descriptor
somewhere and and have it running
entirely out of complex infrastructure
but we'll talk a bit about alternatives
to that
so what if you could write this and you
know
get
this scheduled as part of your pipeline
and have this
run
over time and then whenever a problem
happens you'll be notified that that'd
be ideal
um
and so this is kind of um this is a demo
that i will narrate
because i don't have a computer here
but i also realize
the quality of the
font is probably not great is it can you
read stuff
it looks like there has been some
compression so maybe when i press play
things are a little bit better are they
a bit better
okay so i can't really see very much but
um so i've basically in inserted this
this normal distribution here
and here i'm
generating the the reference so i'm
capturing the distribution descriptor at
this time and this ultimately under the
line just runs the select of your column
maybe with a filter of like a certain
date and you can see here that this
generates sort of this file that holds a
bunch of pins and a bunch of like
histogram values right
um
and then what i'm going to do after this
is i'm going to run a scan of soda that
points to the check file where i define
the distribution difference
i'm going to run this it looks like this
by the way so just what you saw before
so
applied on the order price column using
this reference file
um so
i think here i'm going to be running the
scan
and in that instance i run it on the
same data that i generated the
reference file so it passes okay
so that's all good now i'm gonna
add a little bit of mess in this data
i'm gonna add or
fakely change the distribution to
that orange one doing the same thing so
i'm just putting this data in the
database right now quickly on the left
um and then here i think the word fail
should
is there um so that's sort of that's
that's demo of the other feature right
the idea is
it should be as easy as that and it it
can be if you have um a tool that allows
you to
easily define something
uh use a set of you know built-ins for
this um and and a way to just to
abstract away the sort of complex oh i
have to save my data somewhere how do i
save it do i save it as like as a
descriptor do i save it in s3 all of
that kind of fun stuff
so that's that's one way of doing it um
so what's next
obviously so this feature by the way is
available yesterday uh so it's uh
something that we wanted to start um
soda has
been around for for a while now and it's
been mainly focused on um on
let's say simpler validation rules with
thresholds and stuff like that and
a lot of times
we
you know
for an ml crowd sometimes those you
would want to leverage and that's
perfectly fine but stuff that is a bit
more complex like this and and a few
more uh are a thing that we're um sort
of veering into
so um that's definitely more to come on
here so one of the things that we want
to really do i showed you something that
doesn't give you a lot of output um it
doesn't even give you like the p value
right now because we just built this and
we just want to kind of make it work
but one of the idea is if you were to
connect it to our solar cloud product
you'd be able to see your distribution
plotted in in places but we might also
offer this as in the open source tool
and that we're doing it
and obviously we want to be able to
offer a lot more control over the
different algorithms that are used for
for this so i used this ks test uh for
categorical data you'd use a chi-square
test which we have as a built-in but you
know the there is a plethora of uh of
methods available out there and
depending on the data underlying data
that you have for yourself you you might
want to be able to control that so our
language will extend to allow users to
request specific algorithms or
because the code is open source
implement their own
and help us build
and extend this kind of thing
obviously what i showed you
earlier uh this this approach of
saving bins and weights has some
problems uh i'm sure that you know the
data scientists in here are like oh this
kind of has some problems because then
you have to recreate your data you know
from these
discretized things so we that's that's
true and we can talk about this uh
further like how it works um if you want
but we want to be able to maybe offer a
way to instead of you saving a
descriptor to a file maybe upload a
sample of your data into a storage and
then we'll take care of getting it
wherever uh it needs to be and then
comparing the data to data rather that
data to a reference object
um and then um obviously because we this
is essentially a generic test for for
different distribution comparison we
want to do something which uh sort of
has convenience wrappers around drift
like you could say well monitor drift uh
this model on this set of features um
here are some labels like do your thing
right kind of like a just
convenience in the in the language for
for this to happen
um
all right so as i said it's available
and it's all open source doesn't even
require um connecting to our solar cloud
it's all
able to work for you right now um so you
can head over to our docs to find out a
bit more and i'm happy to answer more
questions here you can install it by
doing
you know pip install soda core and the
data source type of your um
whatever data store you have um so for
example if you're using snowflake soda
core snowflake and then this
new package that is that that we started
working on which is this scientific
package is going to have a lot more
stuff around distribution anomaly
detection and time series kind of magic
and all this will will be out there um
and the
git repo is also there so if you want to
check how it's implemented if you want
to give us feedback on how badly we did
it or how well we did it feel free to do
that and if you want to also uh
contribute to to this um you know it's
open source you can go you can go ahead
um and
contributing means opening issues is
also contributing by the way
so um yeah and i'll be around we have a
we have a booth and we are doing an
event later today so if you if you want
to come come by
you can do that um and i'll be happy to
talk uh a bit more in details of how we
do the thing that we do
uh whether for distribution or for
other types of checks
so thank you very much for listening
you